[Music]
[Applause]
infrastructure is just the most classic
long now subject it's the slowest thing
we do in the built environment the
biggest so we've got two stalks one
tonight and one coming up next month
from James Fallows that one is matching
it infrastructure and civilization some
of which we saw just now there's also a
thing you might call natural
infrastructure so when you think a
bridge over the river that's
infrastructure but the river under the
bridge is also infrastructure it's how
things get from the ocean to the city
itself the water gets here and there as
a lot of travel happens there it's a big
event and the bridge better be aware of
when the river might flood especially if
there's ice floes well the steady
climate for the last 10,000 years has
been basically the whole of seen the
long nails infrastructure varied a
little bit but nothing like what has
been over much of time this has been a
really quiet 10,000 years climatically
which may be coming to an end and so if
that part of natural infrastructure is
on the move
what should human infrastructure be
thinking about in relation to that
nobody knows that subject better than
solve Griffith
thank you all as sander said I'm
speaking on a couple of weeks notice
so I hand drew my slides to save time I
last talked at the lung now I think in
2007 2009 thank you I've had two
children since then explains the loss of
memory my distinct I distinctly remember
that talk because I was introduced then
as I was again tonight by a man carrying
a knife and I just once do it to know
that I came prepared this time I thought
it was just an odd thing to remember
anyway I'm gonna talk about climate I'm
actually not gonna say a lot about
climate tonight because there's an upset
about that I'm gonna talk a lot about
energy and then I really you know in
some respects tonight is my rethinking
and reprise of the talk I gave a long
time ago which variations of that talk
would have been called the most
depressing talk ever so I'm gonna do my
best for this to actually not be the
most depressing talk ever and I think
that's really embodied in my thoughts
around infrastructure and I'm gonna make
us all think about infrastructure in a
larger way than we might typically do
just in the way that Stewart reminded us
that the water under the bridge is in
the river under the bridges
infrastructure in the same way that the
bridge itself is alright so brief US
history as seen by someone with a
training engineering this is this is how
much energy the US has used since 1800
what you'll notice there there's a
couple interesting things up until 1850
that was sort of the the the real start
of the Industrial Revolution
it was just renewables and biomass that
powered the u.s. you'll see the rapid
rise of coal into 1900 and then the
rapid rise of oil once we got
automobiles and airplanes and then after
World War 2 the rapid rise of nuclear
and you can see renewables sort of
trending up pretty quickly again which
is good news
so it'll pose this slide is to I wants
us to think a little bit longer we're
after all at the long now
so think about this 200 years
represented here some pretty amazing
things happened that no one in 1800
would have suspected such as the
Industrial Revolution we electrified 70%
of homes between 1880 and 1930 think
about that as a enormous social
transformation 75% of the population
moved off farms in the century in the
last century so we went from you know
and we're down at about 2% people now
living on farms it's an unbelievable
shift in in culture and and
infrastructure support that we gave
women the vote we have the civil rights
movement and we just allowed gay
marriage again and I put those sort of
cultural pieces on this map is like
people sitting and standing in 1900
really wouldn't have suspected that
those things were going to happen so
what's going to happen in the next 40 or
50 years which is really the crunch
period for dealing with climate change
and I guess to remind you of these sort
of momentous events that transpired we
actually have enough time for momentous
social change so this is a photograph in
Oakland under the bridge obviously this
is automotive infrastructure and then
you'll see the trains in the foreground
and we're going to talk a lot about the
infrastructure needed to solve the
problem I'm just to quickly cover
climate this is a paper from 1896 by
Iranian time someone said and you can
see it there in yellow the atmosphere
acts like a glass of a hot house so this
described the greenhouse effect up here
carbonic acid now known as co2 is the
problem so he predicted the problem
we've since measured it very well in
both in ice core data and then in the
amount of lowered data set you can see
the seasonal variations this is one of
the famous graphs from Al Gore that's
the last time I talked it belong now we
were at 390 despite people protesting
that we should stop at 350 we're now
over 400 and we really haven't changed
the trajectory of this in the last eight
years this co2 correlates the
temperature that's this graph it's wide
you know if this is the one that
everyone likes to dispute except for the
scientists
I actually think one really
intellectually beautiful thing happened
that I think helps us understand climate
change since I last gave this talk I
can't remember what year this paper came
out 2010 or 2011 this is called the
trillion ton paper and basically they
they you know on the left axis there
you'll see that you know what is the
probability of exceeding two degrees of
warning and they have a whole bunch of
scenarios on this and you could roughly
describe them as just plain bad that's
the average one in the middle wow we got
lucky and then far worse than we thought
scenario and then basically here's the
trillion ton so if we burn a trillion
tons of carbon we've got something like
10 to 40% chance of going over two
degrees of warming or expressed in
another way in a far more technically
accurate way than worse than we thought
or well we got lucky scientists have
actually now negotiated what very likely
likely may be unlikely and very unlikely
is seriously this is what the IPCC do
sometimes it's not all they do I hope
anyway we're likely not guaranteed is
staying below two degrees if we stay
under the trillion tons so unfortunately
this is all the reserves of gas oil coal
and then some of the co2 that we will
get from land use changes you'll see
that if the mouse is rolling over it
basically you have to stop here and we
definitely can't burn all of the
reserves so what do you do to do that I
guess in in peak Al Gore
the answer was put solar cells in your
roof changed LEDs and buy an electric
car and I in just a much more anally
retentive way felt trapped to the same
problem so this is actually a slide from
my 2009 talk this is every single
activity in my life measured in what so
that's the sort of constant rate of
power for that activity to go on and so
I could compare all of my life and it
looked wonderful and it gave me the
appearance of authority because I had
done so much math and it bamboozled
audiences in fact I gave this talk often
enough that I was able to test this talk
in every possible set of units so I've
given this talk in watts I've given that
in kilowatt hours per day I've given it
in BTUs in quads even in horsepower and
I actually think for the average
audience that the that when I gave the
talk in horsepower I think 25 percent of
people thought they got all of it which
was far higher than when I talked to him
was so anyway that is to say all I
really learned from all of that detail
was that you know roughly bottled water
stupid use cold water detergent read
your newspaper online stead of on your
device big fight in my family over
canceling six out of seven days of the
subscription to the newspaper on that
one LED lighting is good be more
vegetarian got to make cars better on
the technology side got to improve the
HVAC heating cooling in buildings and in
order to stop flying you got to make
video conferencing not suck which
tragically given that we're living in
the information age is the thing that
we've made the least progress on as far
as I can tell anyway so that was one
version two summary of that over detail
that I used to get and I think it
actually led to this very typical
environmentalist replying refrain of fly
less drive less this is good though pay
less tax so because the government
spends your tax dollars doing stuff that
those dollars use energy so
you could actually say that you don't
pay tax you don't use that energy so
that was the good libertarian side of
this but otherwise it was pay less tax
buy less stuff shall will last you in a
smaller colder house my wife and I
actually enacted that plan we have a 670
square foot Victorian work in a cold
office and eat less meat so there you go
and I kind of think this is the route
that environmentalists got stuck in and
I don't think it actually allows us to
move forward I think the real problem is
it makes you have to make the right
environmental decision at every every
minute of every day this is not really
how you solve a problem so the Romans
were the first to have population
densities high enough that people's
drinking needs and crapping or pooping
needs for one of them needed to be dealt
with so they built the first
infrastructure so this is one of the
aqueducts and I can't remember the name
sadly but in doing so rather than make
you have to think every time all day
that you know if you you know pre
aqueduct room you had to be consciously
aware of how much water was left and
when you're going to get water from
cetera et cetera and then we made it
easy and unconsciously you would solve
your water problems every day because we
build infrastructure and I'd like to now
sort of suggest that we we have to build
infrastructure sorry don't laugh yet
we need to build infrastructure to solve
the problem so that we don't have to
think about it every day because I think
we're not going to you know yes there's
a few environmentalists in this audience
who are very happy to have every waking
hour lowering their carbon footprint but
I don't think that scales for
civilization I was in a race last time I
spoke to finish a book about everything
I'm talking about tonight I completely
lost that race to my good friend David
McKay he wrote a wonderful book called
sustainability without the hot air you
should read that he and I traded
backwards and forwards on climate and
energy and issues for years and he's
told me one of the wisest things I ever
heard
which is all human activity is folly
because if you get hung up in the
details about energy and climate you
want to try it off not doing this versus
doing that and he said no look this this
not there's no human activity that's
better or worse than anyone elses
[Laughter]
I wonder how many people here know my
true feelings on this matter so I didn't
know two or three years ago the Burning
Man organization came to me and said
we'd love to talk to you and engage with
you to be a spokesperson on the
environment and climate for Burning Man
and I don't know it was a it was a
particularly bad day and by pure
coincidence the Friday night before I
had gone to Oakland Coliseum with my
four-year-old son to see the monster
tracks and basically house I just didn't
really know if - sounds like you had no
[ __ ] idea or something was well it
said there's you know Burning Man is the
least green thing in the world right so
you take all of these people you make
them drive a long distance out into the
desert they air-conditioned open tents
with diesel and that gets worse every
year and I'm gonna build you an argument
they'd be father you have humbled people
drive efficient cars all to a
centralized location to watch only two
or 20,000 people go and watch two or
3,000 horsepower cars drive in circles
that's super efficient so I kind of said
I I won't be the the climate
spokesperson for Burning Man until I'm
invited to be a climate spokesperson for
the monster truck foundation which would
have been much more fun anyway so I
didn't either gig
I still believe it's true and I kind of
I think you know the old jokes aside I
think the serious point is and the other
you know the big problem with the
environmental movement news we've been
very preachy and I think if you just
always remember look all human activity
is folly is it really horrible - once a
year go and thoroughly enjoy this I mean
I was it really it's kind of like Disney
on four wheels it was tremendous another
sage friend of mine Tim Anderson I asked
him when I was giving the world's most
depressing talk how do I make it not so
depressing how do I describe a future
that's awesome
and Tim very wisely said well it's
obvious and he was like he didn't even
take much time thing about it's like you
know in the future we will hunt monk
raised bison from electric SUVs on
Thursdays
which honestly sounds like a pretty cool
future but I think Tim's point was yeah
it's not like there's gonna be no
testosterone or there's not gonna be
there's gonna be like no joy in the
future so if you want to get people to
sign up we it should be super fun and I
think in here it's like well here's all
the super fun testosterone-filled
activity with the bowhunting electric
monster truck but actually in a more
deep sense it's like we only do it on
Thursdays so there is some sense of
limits and there monk raised Organic
Bisons so we do it things in the right
way respectful of the world and you know
I think we need that more positive
vision so I'm now gonna go ahead for the
rest of the talk and every time you
think I'm making a judgement about
something just remind yourself that all
human activity is folly and I made his
fee reflecting that all right so to go
back to solving this problem and and and
fixing the bat what do you do
and then regain reminding myself this is
Hoover Dam that we're gonna think about
changing the infrastructure in the right
way let's go back to that pie chart so
thinking and this is where I want you to
start to expand your definition of
infrastructure so when I say improve
government spending you know this is our
cultural and social and political
infrastructure you know we have to
improve the way we spend taxes so that
they don't consume as much energy or
produce as much co2 improve the quality
of our collective stuff the things we
own this is again this is sort of a
cultural infrastructure because it's
Abbas I as collective desires that work
improving our food now diet so we need
to think about agriculture as an
infrastructure improve our civil
infrastructure so in a very deep sense
of and planning and any architect or
even planner and the audience knows this
this is one of the the most important
pieces of the puzzle
start to think of the not urban
transport like Bart as infrastructure
but also think of our collective fleet
of cars as our sort of your personal
infrastructure it's in the sense that
infrastructure is something that you
purchase once and lasts for a long time
in your life you know cars are a piece
of your personal infrastructure or your
transport Cemal it's same with your
house your house is part of your
personal infrastructure and then the the
the collective national set of houses is
is our infrastructure improve the build
environment so that's all the things you
know the social and cultural
infrastructure of all the rest of our
buildings
you've got to improve the internet
because shockingly the internet is
rising up to use a lot of energy but it
may be in a good way and then I still
don't have an answer for flying and
video conferencing that's the remainder
term so if we do all of those things we
should be able to shrink this get more
efficient when the comps in the economy
in a combination of new technologies and
thinking about an infrastructure I think
we can actually get to a good solution
which brings me to ship this is a sewage
plant kind of infrastructure is all
unpleasant things you don't have think
about every day that the difficult
things like bringing buckets of water up
the hill and and and cleaning up after
yourself so how you know again how do we
build infrastructures so that we don't
in the same way we don't really wish to
you know deal with our own sewage every
day let's build the infrastructure so we
don't have to deal with our own co2
effluent so this is my house this is the
670 square foot house in San Francisco
that's called there it is on Bernal it's
actually love a little house there's a
street there's our house it's a gigantic
25 foot by 80 foot San Francisco light
that's 2,000 square foot 200 square
meters all right quick primer and solar
energy thousand watts per square meter
of Sun comes down through the atmosphere
at noon at the equator but there's some
of its absorbed in the atmosphere some
of it is reflected off clouds
obviously there's day/night cycles and
the insulation so
the net amount that hits the ground
spans roughly a hundred to three hundred
and thirty watts per square meter a
hundred in in sort of far north and far
southern cold places and three hundred
and thirty in places like Arizona in San
Francisco it runs roughly 150 to 290
throughout the year
anyway you then collect those with solar
cells that are about ten to forty
percent efficient you can't cover the
ground 100% with solar cells or maybe
fifty to seventy-five percent I think
it's pretty reasonable with really good
solar cells these days to get 25 to 35
watts per square meter so the average
American which I'm now going to assume I
am eleven thousand watts of my power I
need I would have to cover a hundred
percent of my lot and 80 percent of
Melissa's house in solar cells just to
power me so you can see you know in this
old Al Gore world where we're going to
solve it by putting PV on our rooftops
and buying an electric car you can
already see that it's starting to break
down most of us don't have enough enough
infrastructure of our own so we need to
rely on it it's actually worse than that
so this is my family of four out for
Pride this year there they are my I just
showed that photo of my wife because
it's hilarious
don't know what she was thinking it's
she more stoned there or the dog here
so we also have a dog anyway with my
family of four plus dog at the average
insolation value for Sydney for San
Francisco
excuse me step back in time hi mom
not only do I need to cover a hundred
percent of our land right so not just
the roof so a hundred percent of my
little lot I need to cover Melissa's and
the Lopezes and I can't remember two
more neighbors up the hill it's amazing
you can only go to neighbors up and you
forgot the names
that's society and culture right there
so that's in the summer so obviously
infrastructure problem but in the winter
you can see this is the daily solar
insolation in kilowatt hours per day per
square meter you can ignore all the
units in this talk I really am trying to
get to a place where people come on this
understand this talk just on the
pictures come tell me later how I did on
that anyway in winter there's a lot less
solar so actually from my family of four
during winter if we were going 100%
power our lives from the best solar
cells you can get today installed better
than we can today I need basically the
entire block and a little bit of the
block next to us
so that should tell you something about
the sort of I'll buy a Tesla and solar
cells approach as not enough we have to
think about this again as infrastructure
because the problem and the size of the
problem is much bigger than ourselves so
is it any better for the city of San
Francisco hilariously I was invited to
join the mayor's San Francisco 100%
renewable by 20 I can't even remember
what date they were gonna but we were
gonna be a hundred percent renewable buy
and I went to the first meeting all
excited to be invited to be on this
thing and was prestigious turns out
there were only two people in the room
with technical backgrounds and there
were roughly 18 developers lobbying for
their interests at the mayor's request
to do 100 central energy I said is
nuclear renewable they said no of course
nuclear is not renewable
we're gonna disconnect from the
californian grid and they said no and
then well okay then you have to somehow
redefine it then it got worse from there
okay
seven by seven miles the co San
Francisco we use 5.2 gigawatts of power
on average throughout the year we need
120 percent so this is a solar cell roof
like shade structure right not only over
all of San Francisco but on top of Carl
so we don't take the hit for for Carl
taking the Carl's the fog I learned that
for my son anyway in winter it's even
worse we need we need half a marine
Treasure Island and a whole lot of the
bay again there's an even bigger carport
to solve the problem so you know quite
literally San Francisco can't produce
its own power so again we got to think
in a much bigger infrastructure stance
to solve the problem which actually
we've done before which is the good news
so here we are 49 square miles 120
million square meters we get 24 inches
per year of rain except for the last 10
years actually San Francisco yeah well
yeah we're doing bad 26 minutes for year
so we need 73 million cubic meters we
get 73 million cubic meters of water
hitting San Francisco that's hitting
every square inch so if we could trap it
all we'd get that much unfortunately
that's how much we use so the point
being here is that when we design the
city or if I don't know whether how much
forethought they were using we did this
and we got Hetch Hetchy right so we
needed this huge water infrastructure
because San Francisco could never be
stand on its own two feet and so we get
our water from here and we planned that
infrastructure and so really on the
energy generation side thinking about
effluent again this is another sewage
plant I have a lot of photographs of
these things now
how do we how do we plan our
infrastructure in the energy sense so
that we we have something equivalent to
Hetch Hetchy for us and so that forces
you to think about you know how big is
our solar cell or are we gonna use some
biofuels as a biofuel refinery or a
geothermal plant how much about
geothermal or where are we allowed to
use some nuclear so all right now the
super quick primer how much power or an
G in your power is just energy per unit
of time so how much power does humanity
use us all use somewhere between 10 and
20 terra watts of power and that's the
only unit don't need to know it any more
accurately than that if you captured all
of the energy in all the world's oceans
going up and down you'd get about three
and a half terawatts so a small fraction
of humanity's power and it's a pretty
disruptive process you can see this is a
tidal power station where they dam off
the entire estuary and you let the water
flowing in and out through turbines so
it's pretty disruptive and even if you
did all of it
you don't really provide a huge amount
of power so this is a super niche
technology and there's coastal waves and
then the surfer in me got to this this
was when I got the most distracted in
preparing this talk was looking at wave
photos choosing the best wave photo was
very difficult for me so we just went
with a sort of you know a nice you know
8 foot shoulder classic and then I had
to have this photo because it's amazing
anyway sorry back to coastal waves it
really got me distracted ok coastal
waves if you put a magic machine around
every coastline of every every piece of
land on earth you only get three
terawatts of power and then you don't
have any more of these so we're not
gonna do that this is awesome it's not
it's kind of this with it's obviously
not a deep ocean wave because it's
hitting a Welsh lighthouse quite close
to shore but it was obviously a deep
ocean wave that made it most of the way
to shore it's just mind-boggling so
there's a lot of power out there 60
Terra
but it's super hard to get wind that
there's a huge amount of it 400 to 3600
terawatts of it depending upon how high
up you go that's what I spent some
number half of the years since I last
talked here doing was was pioneering
with a bunch of incredible people
McCarney power doing airborne wind
technology they're going to be launching
their first I think roughly half a
megawatt systems early next year or late
this year which is super exciting
anyway wind is great as don't look like
that but these are still cool I think
they're beautiful neither one does
hydroelectric if you'd and every river
in the world you want to get about half
of humanity's power and we already use
quite a lot of hydroelectric so that's
what this looks like and it is pretty
disruptive to the environment if you
burnt every single piece of green stuff
that grew on land on every continent
every year you only get you know three
to four times humanity's power supply so
biofuels are interesting but let's
temporarily azzam a bit looks like that
although it looks quite beautiful that's
probably why not biofuels I should check
that
more than two weeks next time Stuart
so ocean bio people want to use algae
this is totally a lying photograph
that's actually a seaweed farm to make
yuppie seaweed crisps or something but
some people argue there's another 20 20
or 30 terawatts of biological energy in
the oceans to get so maybe geothermal 25
to 30 terra watts
so it's comparable to humanity's in
Iceland it's great where it's close to
the surface and easy to get to there's
the ocean thermal gradient but I put it
in pink to not take it too seriously
because it's super hard to get and we'll
ignore it for a second anyway Solar is
gigantic it's huge so solar you know and
that's why we're seeing a lot of this is
really good if you kind of apportioned
transparency to these things in
proportion to the likelihood that they
sold the problem we're going to be
mostly doing solar and wind with some
hydroelectric some bio and some
geothermal and alright quick tutorial on
power density so like we explained
before you get about 35 watts per square
meter for solar if you do it really well
I think the most bullish technologists
out there would double this in the next
50 years
so we're within a factor of 2 of as good
as you're ever going to do as defined by
Einstein in 1908 so go pick a fight with
him if you don't believe me
wind unfortunately after space all those
turbines a long way apart so you only
get about 2 to 3 watts per square meter
you can still use the land but in
between them but probably only to grow
biofuels and I segue 1/2 to watts per
square meter so for an equivalent amount
of energy you can see how much more land
you need as these squares growth just
for fun let's put nuclear in there which
is why you probably have to keep it on
the table because it is super nice and
dense so there you go that's what a
nuclear power plant is everyone thinks
that these big cooling towers of the
nuclear power plant actually the
reactors are over here in these concrete
cells the generators are in this big
brown box and this is just for cooling
the water so actually the limit on
nuclear is actual
how much cold water there is in the
world it's a lot of rivers we already we
take cold water in for the rivers to
cool our what's called thermoelectric
power plants such as a nuclear one coal
is also thermoelectric so you heat water
up make steam run through a steam
turbine and then you flush hot water
back into the rivers and you can't flash
too much hot water back in the rivers or
you cook the fish so we're kind of
getting to the limits in a lot of river
systems and a lot of places of power
generation of the temperature of water
that we can flow back so one if you if
you have a good idea for how to make
waterless cooling towers talk to the
farm benarjee all right so here's our
trade-off roughly if we think that the
four big ones are going to be solar
nuclear biofuels and wind which I do I
don't think there's anything you know in
2007 or in 2009 last time I gave this
talk there was a there was a lot of
excitement about energy then and
everyone thought there were all sorts of
new energy systems on the horizon none
have come true in the past eight years
they're probably not going to come true
this looks like the smorgasbord that we
have and then I'm sort of tried to put
the trade-offs here so more grid
distribution when you have the big
centralized things like nuclear and
solar although that's a little bit going
to be true of wind to solar and wind are
the ones they don't have storage
inherently built-in so if you've got
more and more of those we need batteries
or some way to store that energy for
when we need it either for peak daytime
or winter as we learned earlier more
land required so you've got to give up
more land if you want more wind and more
biofuels and then more other types of
pollution whether that be radioactive in
small quantities or you know certain
particular matter from the burning of
biofuels all right
he's a particularly nice piece of
infrastructure the America did really
well this is your National Forest
National Park infrastructure and it's
important that we grow that
infrastructure in some sense this is one
of our best carbon sinks in this country
so that's just a plug for that type of
infrastructure alright this is where the
solar could go across
south and south west that's where the
wind wants to go there's a lot of wind
on the coasts a lot of wind in the
middle not so much and the other bits
that's probably where you want to grow
all your plants and because it's we're
in San Francisco let's put all the
nuclei right here yeah this okay it's
very fashionable to make jokes about
Washington
you know it's very fashionable to say we
only need 100 by 100 miles of solar in
the desert and everyone says this and
you hear it over and over and over again
I don't think that's a very useful
because it's not how it's not how we're
gonna build it I very very unlikely and
I don't think it's very useful for us to
visualize the size of the infrastructure
that we're talking about so he is a
gated community somewhere there's a lot
of roofs there I think we have a hundred
and seventeen million housing units in
America if you put those perfect solar
cells covering 75 percent of the roof of
all of the housing units in America all
of our houses you get about 0.8
terawatts it's about a quarter of what
America uses today this is a beautiful
piece of infrastructure this is the
United States highway system snapshot in
1920 it's kind of shocking to me that
was already so well developed right
twenty years after cars came along look
how quickly we rolled out that
infrastructure and and remember that
anyway we can't now have 8.1 milling one
six seven million Lane miles of roads
and their average 11 foot wide things
you learn on Saturday mornings if you
covered all of them with those same
solar cells you get about 1.6 terawatts
so I think the most the easiest way for
me to tell you how to visualize what is
the infrastructure change that we need
it's like we basically need another set
of roads next to every other road you're
driving on
that's solar cells and we're gonna put
PV on every single roof right and
that'll mostly cover America's power
power problem I happen to think if you
think about it right in some respects
think of this map okay no no I'm not
going to go back anyway think of the map
that didn't have roads on it that
existed thirty years before this one we
have the national highway system so
we're gonna do that I hope I think we
can all right anyway while we're talking
about roads think about that 250 million
cars we own is a collective piece of
infrastructure that has a huge role to
play in this energy system that we talk
about this is from the National
Household transport transit survey this
is a histogram of the number of miles of
each trip you take you drive by the
frequency with which we drive all of
those trips this is a huge field of
brand new f-150s the most popular car
ever although I think they totally
cheated we made fifty five million VW
beetles that were very much like the
original and they were way cuter and the
f-150 is called their 450 but they
changed it tons just cheating I am a car
node which turns out sucks if you're an
environmentalist Nakano we'll come back
to that but all human activity is folly
right
twenty-five percent of vehicle miles our
trips less than eight miles think about
that one quarter or less than eight
miles that is quite unbelievable
to me these are maybe better or smaller
has another 25% of trips a fully fifty
percent of our trips are eighteen miles
or less anyway so bit of a history
lesson for the car not in the audience
who didn't grow up in America so I don't
really know my Mustangs and my Chevy's
but boy do I know European crap
the French president jealous that Hitler
had had Porsche designing
the VW Beetle asked citroën to go ahead
and design a car for the people and it
was in it was extraordinarily French was
like this the design spec was it should
carry four passengers you know a couple
of loaves of bread it should have you
should be able to have drive your eggs
to market over an unplowed field without
breaking the eggs literally this was the
French for yeah I'm I'm not joking and
the designers name was Bollinger and
accepted the task and he delivered this
vehicle which which had a 300cc engine
so that put out nine and a half
rip-roaring horsepower he got 65 miles
per gallon we did that in 1948 and it
weighed 1300 pounds some of the light
weighting measures they did there was no
metal roof it was a piece of canvas you
sat in hammocks because that's the
lightest way to make a seat this was a
deathtrap at all speeds but I actually
loved it it's called the ugly duck it's
the dish of oh okay everyone in Europe
post-world war ii made some amazing
efficient little car this is the Fiat
engine quinta the Fiat 500 or the
Bambino it came in 1957 with a huge 479
cc engine 43 miles per gallon and
weighed 1,100 pounds I actually was at
the fiat dealership on Saturday more you
know more to go on that story you can
buy a 2015 version of that same car that
pretends to be called the Fiat 500 with
a 1400 cc engine getting 34 miles per
gallon more than doubled away same story
with beetle 1950 was the original 1,100
CC is 36 miles per gallon 1,300 pounds
this year model 1800 CC 29 miles per
gallon so worse again weighs 3,200
pounds has a huge number of cupholders a
little thing for a flower in the middle
to remind you how green it is compared
to the original my personal favorite the
Mini Cooper S I learned to drive I was
eight years old I could reach the pedals
my father total that my mother never let
him get another one it was a deathtrap
1959 848 CC Leyland meaning 36 miles per
gallon
350 pounds and the new one again lower
fuel economy bigger engine double the
weight quadruple the smugness even our
SUVs got worse 1948 Land Rover weighed
2,500 pounds got 24 miles per gallon the
2015 cheating using diesel which has
higher energy content gives 20 miles per
gallon more than doubled away alright so
you can see the trend we did all of
these weight doubling was really done
mostly so we could go a bit faster and
or wait in traffic longer and also for
safety reasons okay he's the first one
that really changes the equation so this
is actually a car that my wife and I
leased on Saturday or Sunday I can't
remember because the kids were screaming
so much kids hate car dealerships protip
anyway 112 miles per gallon electric car
I believe that they are giving them away
on these screaming lease deals to try
and meet the cafe standards so they can
sell the Maseratis for profit because
it's the same company okay but the
hundred twelve miles per gallon is only
equivalent let's talk about hundred
twelve miles per gallon equivalent right
if you're running it off the California
electricity grid here's the composition
of the California electricity grid in
2014 forty percent natural gas twenty
nine percent other inputs that's dirty
[ __ ] from other states that we don't
want to call it that because for
Californians five percent big hydro amps
in small hydro and geothermal tiny bit
of coal six percent nuclear solar and
wind are actually doing really well
growing really fast but basically if
you're running this at off that dirty
grid you're actually getting you know
this type of fuel economy in reality
because you're just burning fossil fuels
elsewhere and it'll net out about the
same so that is to say when someone says
I bought one of these aren't I great
you're like well only if you're doing
that right and we may discuss that and
I'm now going to switch units because
it's useful for the next piece electric
cars it makes more sense to talk about
the what hours of energy used to drive a
mile all right before we get there
2009 we were pregnant my wife was
pregnant
it's nice to pretend that I was helpful
I was helpful I was so concerned I was
like oh we have to have a safe car
because we had the two-seat Honda
Insight the the really efficient one
they go 200 miles per gallon all
aluminum you couldn't feel a baby
sitting in there so I went to the
Volkswagen dealership and I wrestled
between well I've before I went to the
dealership I wrestled between these two
cars because in 2009 you could get a
Prius or you get the Volkswagen Jetta
sports wagon and they both got 40 to 50
miles per gallon and when you drive the
Prius you felt like it was an insult to
all Italian men it is the least
passionate car in the in the history of
the universe so all right but I'm now
regretting that because as we all know
this week these bastards slide which is
terrible because we didn't take the
$7,000 trade-in and now we got a car
that no one wants to buy all right this
is actually the huge thing that happened
sometime in 2010 2011 the Prius actually
became a plug-in which is awesome do you
remember this 50% of our miles are less
than 50% of our troops are less than 20
miles if you have a plug-in car you'll
almost never use the gasoline if all of
those troops of that so you're really
only gonna use the gasoline when you're
needed which is for long trips and I
would now argue that the Chevy Volt and
the Prius if you can't buy an
all-electric car because you really
really are anxious there's a lot of
anxious people in the city it's more and
more than they used to be too sadly but
you should get one of these and forget
these rotten bastards they lied to me
all right I actually think it's an
amazing time I don't know one of the
questions I often get asked about this
is you know is this a technology problem
or it's a cultural problem honestly I
think climate change is a cultural
problem a social problem but technology
enables you to have new technology lets
you have the conversation in a new
every time so I think there's and we
have an incredible opportunity if we
want to think broadly about
infrastructure we want to think broadly
about transport because of the rise of
these cute little autonomous cars so I
asked my friends Google X to tell me how
many watt hours per mile they refused
because that's so top-secret so as
estimated from this which is an electric
golf club and because their Google
engineers they wouldn't do quite as well
they yeah I don't know they shouldn't
they shouldn't keep secrets from us like
that but see they've benefited they
might be doing the right thing right 150
watt hours per mile is going to be two
or three times it's going to be twice as
good as our electric feared two or three
times as good as a Tesla if you put two
people in it's going to be great and
because they're autonomous we might be
able to solve a lot of the traffic
problems and you'll actually get to the
end goal faster but the that we should
be having a conversation right now
around autonomous cars about the much
broader one we're having is basically
uber fighting with Google over whether
it's going to be a big one or a little
one and when you're allowed to use it as
opposed to hey if we think about like
public transit infrastructure and
autonomous cars maybe we can have a
totally better win for society
incidentally I wanted this and my wife
said no way also I think it's amazing
and you know going back to the histogram
of how we want to travel we because of
this the rise of the cheap battery and
the rise of cheap electric high power
density electric motors we now have
amazing skateboards this is a local
product love it this is also a local
product I don't know Karlsson the
audience this is the one we all this is
awesome about 25 hours mile some people
don't like it some people love it not
going to say anything myself 35 hours
from mile all human activity is folly
this is yeah I hope you're clapping the
guy in this is actually sitting in the
front row and I wouldn't have pointed
that out except on my way over here he
pointed out that I already had sweaty
armpits and so I'm like well yes you do
look like a goofball in this photo then
but there you are getting 15 25 watt
hours per mile with you know four people
on it so maybe you know five watt hours
per mile that's pretty cool
I built this and I've been writing that
I've done in the last six years 8,000
miles on that at 20 to 30 watt hours for
mile with the dog the kids the groceries
these sort of light electric vehicles
really can change your game so I would
yeah we should all clap thank you and we
should be like we should engage those
things in the deeper conversation about
transport infrastructure and what we
want our world to look like we're still
not building bike lanes fast enough let
alone dedicated whole streets to
beautiful fun things like those anyway
come back to this so these are the watt
hours per mile of all those vehicles and
you can put them roughly on that map
like that this is the cool future we
could live in not everyone looks cool on
these though I have to say some of them
look like they should have learn to ride
a skateboard first all human activity
this is but I never thought I would say
the things that are gonna come out of my
mouth I love trains I love trains the
way three and four-year-old boys love
trains if you've had a three or
four-year-old boy you know what I mean
you probably have boxes of Thomas in the
Attic I love trains sadly if you look at
all the history of our bad and most
rapid transit systems outside of New
York and London where they have
unbelievable population as you get about
220 watt hours per mile per passenger
and the land use is not terribly good it
takes a lot of land to build all the
railway tracks and so intercity is even
worse than the fast you go well it
doesn't make too much difference because
there
they're so long but you now compare
those back to these other modes of
transport you know obviously the two
things on the Left where you can easily
average 10 to 15 miles per hour the you
know the Google micro thing and mean
thing does it have a name yet does
anyone know someone here must be working
on it you wouldn't tell me anyway I know
all right
I never thought I would say the
following thing either a better piece of
public infrastructure than trains might
be just making autonomous Tesla's where
you guarantee that you have two or three
people in them all the time right so in
some weird mashup of google buys uber
but Tesla runs it you could imagine 137
watt hour per mile public transit system
with this maybe this vote Hillary can do
if she doesn't win next year run this
it's couldn't get any weirder but the
point is it's like seriously there is an
opportunity to change the debate around
public transit and then I'll come back
more to that so you know I think this
should be the goal and I don't care how
we do it if it's the alphabets or the
pink I love pink as my daughter says all
right so we're going to get the
infrastructure that we asked for and
this is just a bit of a gripe about the
way we do it all right so the Tesla
there's no limit on how much power
you're allowed there's no speed limit on
that thing although there are practical
speed limits and you get a $7,500
subsidy on a luxury item right we have
bizarre 500 watt power limits on the
bicycles electric bikes on the right
that is absurd we should have had a
torque limit and that talk limit should
have been designed to climb up any hill
in San Francisco so you can barely buy a
legal electric bicycle thing job bills
in San Francisco because we legislated
that possibility out of existence while
allowing the thing on the left occur we
have a 20 mile per hour speed limit
seems arbitrary and we don't have a
subsidy
yet we know the histogram of road miles
traveled right we're going to get you
know we're going to get the climate
outcome that we build the infrastructure
for and we're going to subsidize the
thing on the left and we're not going to
give families like that on the right the
right infrastructure I'm not really
wanting to beat up on terror I know it
sounds like that but I think it is fair
to say the option on the right is a lot
more affordable to a lot more people and
you could give to families that for the
subsidy you give one wealthy family to
buy a Tesla alright I take back
everything I said about the Segway I
actually want to live in this world and
this is if we're if we're totally going
to reimagine infrastructure and we want
to bow hunt monk raised bison from
segways on Thursdays but I actually like
this could actually be our commute there
is no reason you would have higher
passing high throughput more efficient
they put putting all these people things
like this let's have a dedicated lane
surrounded by beautiful gardens with a
cornucopia of wheeled electrical things
that are super fun right all of these
things are fun even the Segway that's
that's me going to get ice cream with my
kid you can see him in the back that is
the most clothed you will typically see
him it is a hat and underwear so that's
winning that's three of his best friends
so this is this is what for what our per
mile transport looks like so in your
minds mashup of that in that right as
the future of public transit it could be
awesome all right let's think about
housing is infrastructure I'm gonna
speed up a little bit I think all right
that's pretty depressing when you talk
about housing your structure its really
all about heating and cooling so let's
go back why can I say that with such
confidence there's our house on
Manchester Street there's the solar
insulation so you can see we don't get a
lot of energy hitting the house in
winter and we get you know three three
times as much in summer this is our PG&E
bills for the last three years
we were on we actually were on extended
out-of-country
vacation which is why the data for 2012
looks low come back for 2013 what you
can see here the red line is a thermal
load in watts per square foot the blue
line is the electrical load so we're
using 500 watts or well half a half of
what per square foot for the house we
use maybe 500 watts for the whole house
of electrical load that's tiny and the
thermal load completely dominates and
especially in the winters not only were
away I really spent that year because it
was closest to when I'd last you in this
talk debating the thermo setting some
stats sitting with my wife I lost it so
the next year I installed insulation
because that should help and it did a
tiny bit and I looked at this graph I
was like whoa installation the
insulation killed it and then I went and
looked at this data this is really
shocking okay 2012 is the coldest year
so lower down on the graph colder 2013
was a little bit warmer 2014 was warmer
again and in fact I this is super nerdy
i graphed the watts per square foot
versus the average daily temperature for
the house and you can see that as it
gets colder the electrical goes up a bit
because you're inside doing things with
electricity and you're inside using heat
so it makes total sense which combined
with that totally means that these were
just warming years which is also to say
it is extremely difficult to retrofit a
hundred year old Victorian that is made
out of cardboard it's very charming it
was built the year after the earthquake
to provide housing so this is the data
for the whole nation in watts per square
foot what this sort of says is as your
house gets bigger you totally get better
you use less watts per square foot and
your electricity goes down your natural
gas goes down your total energy goes
down we should all have giant houses
that's completely obvious because as you
all know if you did high school anything
the surface area is with the square and
the volumes with the cube and heat is
lost through the surface area and heat
is retained in the volume and so that's
why that's true except it's not because
we don't put as many people in the big
houses and you can sort of see here
there's actually this is probably a
graph I shouldn't have hand drawn
because it's super interesting at about
a thousand square foot seems to be the
optimum and then it goes back up if you
look at the housing infrastructure
across the country all right this is a
much better drawing that I can do this
is done by Richard Thompson an architect
who's helping my wife and I design a new
home we're moving from vernal to Bernal
because it's really nice there except
for getting anything built there I
noticed another architect friend of mine
is up there I don't know how they live
with the city by the time this house
gets built I will spend somewhere
between 10 and 20 percent of my living
life fighting with the city to get it
built right which actually is an
unbelievably important point we have to
change infrastructure as fast as
possible which I'm going to get to and
we're making it as hard as possible to
do so this is going to be an
unbelievably green house except for the
things that the city won't let us do
which would be green anyway more in that
I can because I have my data I this I'm
predicting how in my new house is going
to work I changed units again because
you in stone manor just look at the
shapes of the curves electric showers
there's my electric bikes awesome space
here huge and this is assuming that I'm
going to be about three times efficient
because we're insulating a lot and we
won the fight with the architect about
not having windows at the top of the
house where all the heat escapes all of
these glascott X that's our electric
Fiat 6000 miles a year of the electric
feared and barely makes a dent
my wife must have got to the slide set
she grew up in Northern California
apparently this is cultural all human
activity is folly I enjoy having hot
tubs with my wife this may make it into
the budget question mark do thank you
all right and then we've maxed out the
solar on the roof and in fact we put it
at one solar on one south east facing
wall and that's how much power we're
going to get from the solar there's this
huge amount of power that we can't get
we get a little bit more than we need in
summer maybe we'll charge the car to
drive all year oh wait that doesn't work
so huge emphasis like storage is still
the biggest unsolved hard problem here
all right thinking out of the box this
is a cord of wood that is me having cut
my cord of wood cord of wood which is a
glorious unit of energy is 4 foot by 4
foot by 8 foot of wood literally and it
there's there's exchange units into BTUs
and other useless things anyway it's
5,000 kilowatt hours a quarter to a half
a cord per acre per year is considered
the sustainable rate at which you can
just cut up what falls over and you
basically can extract that from your
Woodlands I need three cords of wood to
offset sorry go back that and luckily my
mother-in-law has six acres so we can
get it up in Sebastopol so one day
chopping drive at home in electric
something bike
one day chopping two days riding home
with the electric bike and trail of wood
it's gonna be fun
you thought Burning Man was fun and we
could totally go completely off grid
this is the point we could completely go
off grid in our house if this were
allowed but it's the city of San
Francisco and you're not allowed to put
a new wood-burning stove because of air
quality issues but actually that's kind
of an absurd law because I would prefer
to take a 10% hit on the efficiency of
that burner by putting in a scrubber so
that I could go off the grid but it's
illegal and this is to say we're going
to get the infrastructure that we're
that we allow ourselves and if we're
going to solve this we're going to have
to have more biofuels one of the best
ways to use biofuels could be in this
manner and it's a point of ennui we need
to think better and you know we make
these decisions at city level and some
of them are silly
I don't know helpful diseases just to
say that was our house in San Francisco
we have an ideal climate where this is
the easiest during the Northeast you
need more energy all year round cuz you
need more heat in the winter and you
actually use the air conditioning in
their muggy summers in the south you use
less heat in the winters but you do end
up having a lot more air conditioning in
the middle anyway white goods is
infrastructure while we're on houses
right after you decide to build a tiny
house the next most important thing is
the goods that you fill it with the
refrigerator water heater washer/dryer
that might be a better idea in fact and
because my wife we grew up in Northern
California this is actually our clothes
line not kidding I love her
dishwasher and then shockingly and you
see this and all the statistics our
electronics are now standard dominate
the electrical load some of these large
screen TVs can be close to a kilowatt of
power draw and people like watching a
lot of TV also air-conditioning units
especially the window-mounted ones are
terrible we should use fans but again if
you're thinking about your personal
infrastructure you buy a house probably
once or twice in your life and you buy
white goods probably once or twice in
your life we have to make exactly the
right decisions on that infrastructure
and get the most efficient stuff at
those points otherwise that
infrastructure is locked in your garden
is part of your infrastructure this is
my lovely wife's garden she is a master
gardener and it actually keeps the house
cooler to have that garden and city plan
is everywhere used to you know put
tree-lined streets to provide shade to
keep cities cool it is it offsets the
urban heat island effect you can also
grow some food here which means you open
the refrigerator less often because you
have your own Tomatoes I really would
like to emphasize that we should
consider seriously the notion that
gardening is part of our infrastructure
at that sort of the personal regional
national levels I didn't just say that
to my wife I'm really deadly 100%
serious and I'll back it up with data
that I'm going to hand draw location is
infrastructure so this is super
interesting god this is urban planning
right look at that alright just using
the San Francisco example but this
really applies to everywhere just in
slightly different ways we went out of
our way as to buy this tiny house cuz we
were going to be cold and use less
energy and then we made sure that my
office was like a mile from the house so
that we wouldn't have to drive and then
the Pope goes at San Francisco there's
like four fantastic grocery stores like
within an extra quarter of a mile the
most and our whole life was being lived
beautifully in that one or two mile
radius and then we entered the San
Francisco public school lottery
and we got our seventh choice out of 29
which seems weird because 50% of people
got their first or second choice first
choice so I don't know we we didn't get
that lucky but the school is great and
actually the principal principal Gregory
John should be the very face of American
public education revival he is wonderful
this is commodore sloat unfortunately
it's four and a half miles from my house
so I write you know I do it in the
morning my wife does it in the evening
that's about 2,500 miles per year that
were magically added to a house that had
almost stopped driving that costs us
about seventy five hundred dollars but
rather than giving me seventy five
hundred dollars to buy an electric bike
to ride that we give seventy five
hundred dollars to subsidize some kids
private school right I don't want to
pick on Tesla owners again but we are
kind of not getting this right just yet
okay and you know this would be much
better obviously and I think this is
probably one of the most important
points that I'd like to hammer home if
you think about why we travel and move
so much it's because we want to get from
good place to good place and avoid the
[ __ ] in the middle right so you know
there's a lot of suburbs between San
Francisco and Palo Alto that we kind of
just want to drive really fast past some
of them are pleasant you know I'm not
but but there is there is a set of
people who get in large white buses and
do this every day I'm getting way off
the point okay the point was we drive a
lot to get from good place to good place
and void the craft in the middle right
and if we raise all the boats if it was
just a good public school everywhere we
kind of lived right next to the wrong
one
also I love that you said yay and I
totally believe public education I love
principal Gregory John but you know if
there's a libertarian solution Soviet
but in the good public school everywhere
I think is reasonable and we should
expect that and if you had a good
schools everywhere and they're all local
then you know you wouldn't have to do
this absurd driving isn't you know
there's 80,000 kids in this there's soda
you know and there's 80,000 parents with
the problem that I just said so building
good schools everywhere having good
shopping centers everywhere having good
gardens and good playgrounds everywhere
like that is our civil infrastructure
and we need to get the cojones to say no
to the small government people and and
and say like you know it's easy actually
in our best interest this is how you
create a beautiful world stuff as
infrastructure so we all buy a lot of
stuff sadly we buy them from these
places big-box stores all right so we
ship all of these stuff to the big-box
stores this is a hilarious thing this is
called evergreen Plaza I just you know I
don't really like Google image search as
a as a powerpoint technique but
sometimes you get something great so
yeah this is totally evergreen right
because you put that chopping
infrastructure and then you trap
everyone into thousands of 8 mile trips
as opposed to some other option so again
thinking about how technology may have
changed and this is I think it could be
very very significant so there's my
house in San Francisco there's the big
box score store down in Daly City
there's the big box store over in
Emeryville in fact Emeryville subsidized
all the big box stores so they got the
tax in Oakland didn't which is pretty
naughty right now imagine every single
person in this home doing all these
crazy trips to the big box stores and
and you know there's a lot of
unnecessary miles this is an Amazon
Fulfillment Center I don't want to say
anything good or bad about Amazon but I
do think there is an opportunity to have
a new conversation about our
infrastructure particularly around how
we shop around our commercial and retail
sectors is again yeah the giant place
so imagine you're delivering these
things in this or even better and this
maybe they bottle those robot companies
so this thing will have a robot arm so
it'll robotically deliver everything to
your door and they'll have a profitable
business like Amazon and if you did that
then the big-box stores would come to
you and because they've solved the
travelling sales problem salesman
problem much better I had to say one
nerdy math reference then we'll have
this this would actually be a hugely
more efficient infrastructure my wife's
way ahead of it I think she only uses
Amazon to buy stuff now but this is
interesting so let's have a conversation
about how that plays out this photo is
what we should do with all of those
vacant storefronts and do box stores or
maybe like this I would love this to be
Emeryville who's with me all right where
are we okay this is called the Sankey
chart this is how energy nerds look at
energy again take away the emotional
feeling of this moreso than the numbers
this is how we use produce America's
energy today 35 quads this is unit I
used quads as a unit here that's a
quadrillion British thermal units it's
actually how what the Department favors
for this conveniently America uses
basically 100 quads so think of this is
not in quad units but as in percentages
of America's energy units all right so
from the beginning percentages of
America energy 35% comes from oil 5%
from biomass this is today 18% from coal
28% natural gas ain't hops and nuclear
hydro wind solar geothermal we send
about 38 and a half of those into our
electrical generation infrastructure
most of them are those are our
thermoelectric plants and then they get
then all of that energy goes into our
residential sector commercial sector
industrial and our transportation sector
and you can see the transportation and
the industrial ones are the biggest ones
and residential and commercial are
significant also so this is how it all
gets wired up this is sort of the flow
diagram or
of the lines are proportional so you
should look at the proportions of energy
going in that's how the electricity
flows out from the electric centre into
residential commercial industrial you
can see almost no electricity flowing
out into transport yet because you
haven't been buying enough electric cars
despite everything I've said about
electric cars we want more and
definitely more Electric skateboards so
today we get energy forty quadrillion
energy service units doesn't really
units don't matter but roughly forty
percent of their energy flows through
from where we make it into useful work
and activities that we enjoy all of our
follies forty folly units we definitely
have no these are the follies we have
sixty waste follies so today and you'll
see this so where does all this waste
come from two thirds of it this is why
your grid charged Tesla is not green
because all of that grid is producing
this big-ass waste that goes over here
into the waste follies whereas if you're
running it off solar cell which you
should buy with your seven nine thousand
dollar rebate you just putting a yellow
line down here which would be great
anyway that's how we do it today so
that's crazy
all right here's a different way let's
let's be rebuild our infrastructure from
the ground up and we'll build it
backwards so we want to have the same
amount of folly right we want the same
lovely amount of monster trucking and
burning Manning and segwaying and Tesla
so let's go back from there and I'm
going to sort of give you a narrative
version of how this might work so we
only need roughly half as much energy
into transport because for most of the
light cars and trucks we're going to go
all-electric right and some of the big
long trucking we're going to use natural
gas and yeah
anyway we have the amount in transport
we get a little discount on industrial
commercial basically by improving HVAC
we get a bad
percent win and residential by living in
better designed houses designed by my
other architect up there and the
audience go seeing Mason Kobe Bernal
Heights he'll do you a good deal I hope
[Laughter]
all right and then that all got hugely
more efficient because look how we
electrified a huge amount of the
transportation infrastructure I'm not
telling you what year we're going to do
this by yet that comes later wait for
the punchline
we electrified a huge amount industrial
commercial and residential and then
instead of this old one we'd have a tiny
bit of oil now because you need some oil
for industrial input just assume that we
haven't quite got the biomass doing
everything right yet we do will Federal
bound biomass we do a small amount at
will gas to solve a few problems we
garden the hell out of the place and
make it beautiful to offset the small
amount of fossil fuel burning and the
natural gas we increase nuclear we go
big deep and heavy on solar and same on
wind a little bit of hydro increase
geothermal and look at that we get the
same amount of energy
we've got one-third the waste and right
instead of getting forty percent from
sixty we now got you know two thirds
this is totally a believable version of
this chart you could go and find a lot
of people to argue an eagle and dial
down nuclear because they don't like it
and dial up solar or say they don't like
wind turbines it's gonna not really
affect the gross shape of this this is
possible this is doable in North America
and we should just do this all right and
that's what it looks like and we're
actually our quality of lives have
improved we've ride segways to school on
garden paths we're winning all right
adoption Kurds how much time you have to
do this how many decisions so this is
really the infrastructure it's a calm
adoption curve this is imagine tomorrow
right let's talk in toothbrush units
tooth browser technology toothbrushes
last a month if you have an adoption
curve 100 percent it means that next
week
Colgate makes the best toothbrush ever a
hundred percent of this sign up to buy
that toothbrush in one month a hundred
percent of everyone in the world is
using the best
brush if you have something that lasts a
year it takes a year to get you know a
hundred percent replacement alright five
years ten years twenty five years so if
you buy a car the last twenty five years
it'll take twenty five years with a
hundred percent adoption cut so everyone
bought an electric car tomorrow when
their old gas car died it'll take twenty
five years to replace the 250 million
this might be more realistic adoption
rate this is sort of a free market
adoption rates like oh I might kind of
want an electric toothbrush but I'm
gonna wait and see if my friends who are
early adopters like at first and then
you know that sort of explains from the
first bit so the five percent of people
are buying them and then it gets more
and more popular and by the end of the
day everyone realizes the benefits of an
electric toothbrush and so everyone's
buying one and that rate for a one year
lifetime object you can see on the
bottom axis there it takes twenty years
with an adoption rate like that just to
replace one infrastructure the last for
one year I don't know what
infrastructure lasts for one year so
let's talk about things that last five
years like bicycle bicycles it'll take
you know fifty years if it's a ten year
thing like a washing machine or a car
it's going to take basically six to
fifty or sixty years if we have adoption
rates that aren't more immediate right
so I don't really I don't think this
conversation should be political I don't
really vote here I'm sort of a political
I am definitely becoming more Republican
as I get older so the bottom adoption
curve is you know stereotypically
Republican this is the free market at
work I don't think that really is the
Republican stereotype they fix markets
just like the other guys do the mandated
adoption curves that's the one on the
Left that's sort of the Democrat version
where we all just do the right thing
tomorrow because we magically know what
the right thing to do is all right
I'm really trying to say is actually we
need to do something much closer to the
mandated adoption curve because of this
problem so for most of your stuff that
last one to five years you know you got
to just get the best thing next time
do it when your car comes up for sale
you know if you we really have to
everyone in the world kind of has to
make nearly a hundred percent correct
infrastructure decisions between now and
2050 and if we do that we will do better
than two degrees of warming and that's a
total win and the your life will improve
and you won't you'll have just as many
energy services and you'll have more
streets paved with palm trees it's gonna
be great
but we have to make the right
infrastructure choice every time not
just the individual ones but the
collective ones with our tax dollars and
sort of the large public service kind of
ones how we build out public transit
systems all right coming back to how
realistic is this I did all of this math
for San Francisco person turns out that
your basic we all get 20 if you're the
$850,000 we get 2500 square foot of San
Francisco each right which is you know
250 square meters round ish people in
Boston New York Singapore Hong Kong they
get less thinking about 2,000 square
foot ish I showed you the point here is
to go back and think about like San
Francisco couldn't solve it within their
own borders we needed to lean on larger
larger collective space to build our
infrastructure there are cities in the
world like Macau and Monaco where you
cannot there is no way barring putting a
nuclear plant in the middle of that town
there's no way to go zero carbon in
their footprint right they can't do the
hundred percent solar carport that we
can do here
great alright so reducing the scale of
San Francisco that this is the sort of
population density of San Francisco
versus California versus the population
density of the United States so for
every one person in San Francisco they
get that little tiny green amount and
for every one person the United States
you have this much larger amount of
space right and I showed you that asked
is a San Francisco person if we used one
or two percent of all of the land in the
United State
we can totally get to this green world
by having this solar roadway next to
every roadway so we need to lean on the
larger United States to be able to do
that or in the larger California if
you're on them in the larger California
you need to use a little bit more than
1% of the amount of space because
there's less space per person there are
some countries that can totally do this
easily New Zealand for example is the
biggest one that I could fit on this
screen because when you hand draw your
slides you don't go back and rescale
them Australia Russia they have there
they're just like off the charts so
those places should be net energy
exporters in the future it's going to be
really hard in the United Kingdom
because they don't have much space to do
it
so that's why they're going heavy on
nuclear again that's Bangladesh that's
going to be real tough they don't use a
lot of energy and then we need to have a
good conversation about who gets to use
how much energy all right going back to
the infrastructure did we make any
progress tonight well hopefully I now
have you believing that there's a small
number of decisions in your life that we
need to make correctly and once you've
done that you will just accidentally be
really greener than all of your smug
friends but you have to make the right
decisions and you have to make the first
time every time
all right what are those decisions next
time you buy a vehicle it should be all
electric
if you can't kiss you're just too
anxious and you can't wait to like in
someplace to drink a coffee and charge
your car and come home and read a book
then get a plug-in hybrid but then
that's the last plug-in you ever get and
it's all electric right preferably also
when you buy it make sure you use the
seven and a half thousand dollars to buy
solar cells so that you fully cover it
right so you're not just plugging that
thing into the grid that's naughty bad
super bad you can afford this car you're
buying solar cells
really I think it is unbelievably
exciting so I forgot to make the point
this was a slide to remind me to make
the point that you remember how all of
the old cars were super cool and super
dangerous and super lightweight and then
we added this huge amount of weight to
them to make them safe with autonomous
cars they're gonna be so good they will
never hit each other right we don't need
all of that weight anymore so we could
go back to these super lightweight very
efficient cars again in this autonomous
car world so one side of the autonomous
car debate could be how do we use the
autonomy for good how do you use the
autonomy to make sure they miss each
other so that they're unbelievably
efficient and they become the most
incredibly ubiquitous and clean and
green public transport infrastructure
we've ever had right that could be
awesome I don't see people having that
conversation they won't even tell me how
much energy it uses and you should do
this
also you should tease Henry who's in the
front row when you see him on the way
out this is a better idea right
okay your housing infrastructure if you
build a house build it right first time
suck up all the extra cost to give you a
sense of it it is insane to build this
house to try it to build a house to try
and be green so I had called the Builder
that I know and like on Saturday morning
and I said I'm preparing this talk you
know the house that I might be going to
build if the city of San Francisco ever
gets their [ __ ] together and lets us
build it how much is it going to cost to
put the wiring in that house so just the
conduit just all the wiring it is up to
the including the fixtures I'm talking
about just short of the fixtures so just
put in all the copper wires and circuit
breakers thanks he's like it it'll cost
you $80,000 for a 2,000 square foot home
in 13 San Francisco might be cheaper is
somewhere else in the country and I'm
sure there are cheaper James enough here
in the audience but I'm sure there are
cheaper electricians
I wonder if I this is my price with bid
will go down or up now anyway the point
about that $80,000 is all of the
electricity that goes through this house
because we've designed it to be so
efficient in the next hundred years is
about that cost right and it's the same
with the you but it's a Tesla round
figures as eighty thousand dollars also
it will never you know its lifetime you
won't put eighty thousand dollars worth
of electricity through it so we've got
to rethink it fossil fuels were so cheap
that we you know the upfront cost you
wanted it to be low but now you're gonna
have to pay a big upfront cost and then
Alan ties it over long periods of time
make these decisions correctly by small
ones is even better than buying
efficient ones and definitely dry your
tie ties on the line this is just a
reminder like we have to lobby the
cities that we live in and the plan is
and we have to collectively make better
decisions you have to tell your
employers that it's absurd that we have
to all like drive so much in the white
buses
I may have ridiculed them earlier
they're probably full occupancy they're
about 50 watt hours per mile so every
time you're driving behind that white
bus and you're all in your face
you're changing San Francisco it is
actually the most efficient way to move
those people through all the ugly
suburbs
which is to stress the point that we
have to make everywhere beautiful right
and everywhere has to have a good public
school everywhere has have gardens and
this should be our commute and there's
no white buses be awesome
this is Lord Howe Island they have
you're only allowed to commute by
bicycle I wish we could all live there
the next best thing is fulsome Street I
don't know we live on the top of Bernal
and you look down on all of those north
south facing streets and there's just
all of this ugliness and then there's
it's just vibrant green beautiful Street
and when you walk down I walk to the
office I have a choice I can walk down
Folsom or I can turn right a procedure
and then walk down Alabama if you walk
down fulsome it's cool and pleasant all
year round
because the trees provide this natural
cooling effect in this shade and if I
walk down Alabama it's hot Alabama is
smoother so it's more fun to ride the
skateboard but the point being we need
to you know think about gardening and
trees and green stuff is infrastructure
again there's a great opportunity to
rethink how we do retail and how we do
delivery and how we buy our stuff and I
think we can totally do this now I
probably wouldn't have said that 10
years ago so that's good news and then
up there extra slides so ignore you saw
those and then this is my two-year-old
daughter crossing the bridge in the
Japanese garden and I'd like to finish
on the Japanese garden I think the
Japanese are very wise very old culture
they have one of the lowest per capita
energy consumptions in the world
especially proportional to their quality
of life and it's because they've built
beautiful infrastructure and they
respect things like gardens and I think
we need to also try and think like an
old long culture like Japan and if we do
so we can actually win this Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
not too surprisingly a lot of questions
are about various specific technologies
you are incredibly specific and that
helps so Pete says what about solar
thermal it's 50 percent efficient as a
matter of fact we heat water for pool
and our place in Petaluma solar thermal
doesn't count all I saw was white roofs
that was yeah I I don't know if that's
that Pete Lin it's totally a people in
question all right
so solar thermal is actually I'm super
interested and I didn't write it off I
will give you two anecdotes we I work
with a wonderful woman Leila madrone she
runs a solar company that we started
called Sun folding that is building
tracking devices and we started that
company thinking we were going to be
tracking mirrors for solar thermal
building solar thermal plants they want
to be really large to be efficient I'm
sure that yes they are efficient but
there is a billion dollars each time you
run the experiment and unfortunately
because you can build lots of Cheaper
solders much faster we've had a lot more
innovation and at this point
photovoltaics one the cost curve race
against large-scale solar thermal you
Pete may also be talking about solar
thermal for heating your house I really
looked at doing this and it totally
given the thermal load of our house the
thing in my head that made the most
sense to build was no PV on the roof all
solar thermal collectors was inefficient
twice the efficiency if we would have
got out of TV they don't leak anymore
it's kind of cool the plastic electric
yeah you haven't had a full life cycles
now I'm gonna imagine having a ton of
water above the house and have because
we live on a slope like this it's like
three stories so they're gonna have to
pump it down and we're gonna do in-floor
radiant heating with warm water made we
need to have resized the tank and it was
a four thousand gallon tank which would
have taken up the space for an electric
car and there are earthquakes issues and
you think about the complexity of that
system and it really pained me because I
wanted that to win like I wanted that to
win
and then you're like oh but I could just
do PV and it's gonna just be easier this
is pretty much of an ownership story
you're telling what a renters do so
that's a great that's a great criticism
and you know I I could I use the
narrative of my own life because there's
an easy way to tell a story about
infrastructure I think the question for
renters is is is difficult you would
like to do the right things but you
don't have a huge amount of control so I
think we need to solve the cultural
problems which are putting people off
buying houses because I actually think
that when people invest in their
communities the cultural and financial
issues they're making it harder for
young people to buy houses I don't know
how we solve those they're even harder
than whatever I talked about tonight but
I think people investing in their place
makes better communities so those those
things should happen barring that we
need to make the policy and legislation
things at city level that give renters
better options I don't know I don't know
there must be some I don't know it's
hard whoever asked that question I
workshop it with you on Monday or
Tuesday it sounds like the way you're
really looking at theirs what works for
the landlords it would meet all of these
we have to figure out what works for
landlords and you know there's no it's
no shock that there were 18 landlords on
the 20 person advisory board to the city
of San Francisco on renewable energy
a question from Luke Davis this is all
very optimistic how would all this
change if there was a war basically I
would say I would always what are the
that's one bad thing that might happen
and I get this question too whose I
generally tell an optimistic story
because you've worked a pretty specific
set of plot lines in your optimistic
story what do you know are the major
vulnerabilities to those plot lines one
of the good things about wars we all use
less energy during war and we kill
people
okay that's super doc and that was
optimistic sort of war is bad and
honestly a huge amount of our personal
energy goes into fighting wars so you
know that big quarter or more my pie
chart is is this government fighting
wars over oil so obviously not fighting
wars is sort of being ready to maybe
fight horse this were a whole lot of
that cost goes I think wolf is gonna
change profoundly it already has it's
all about drones and it's not flying
people and cyber war and stuff like
tribal wars so energy-efficient you
prefer war cyber war is an efficient
drone wars range efficient so you know
war is bad and will disrupt that I think
that your point is yes I gave you an
optimistic story because my wife was
sick of me telling that giving the
world's most depressing talk um I
actually am more optimistic now than I
have been in a long while it's not by
tonight I got tired of being not
optimistic are you telling the
psychology or are you actually
responding to something in the world
no I'm responding to something in the
world so you know in in climate change
people talk about tipping points and we
don't have electric cars at the price
point yet that is at a tipping point but
we can in close to one we're at a
tipping point on solar and it's probably
not honestly and I say this is a
technologist it's not really the
technology that gets us to that tipping
point the companies that the green the
green energy companies that have one big
have really been the companies that have
figured out how to do the financing the
best so we've invented essentially
mortgage and financing instruments Solar
City Sun run all these guys and it's
those financing instruments and even on
the rebates for the electric cars that
are making those things affordable and I
think we're gonna get a lot more
adoption so I think those things are
worth being optimistic and then I think
there are a couple of big sea changes
that are coming from technology that
enables us to be optimistic that we'll
design a better infrastructure the
autonomous car what replaces big-box
stores
because I think that can happen you know
it might be Amazon or it might be
something else
so distribution replacing big boxes are
making big boxes more efficient in these
autonomous vehicles which are now small
and not heavy because they don't run
into each other things like that I don't
know exactly how they play out I think
both of those you know if they can move
they can move ten or twenty quads around
what else has changed for you since 2009
when you talked about this which was
when you kind of started to take it on
as I recall I tuned on for a while and I
just felt beat up the what else has
changed for me I had to I think in the
in the air I got older I got two kids
and I had to build the type of
infrastructure that goes with that so
we're sinking routes in San Francisco
and building house and then in deeply
looking at that and using it as a design
experiment and the thought experiment
how do you do it Ryan how do you do this
in a way that works for everyone
it makes you look for a solution
oriented right and I think if you're
humble about the houses so you don't
build the giant you know America is
building bigger and bigger and bigger
houses the average house size is now up
over 2,800
or maybe even three thousand square foot
we're not going to get there on that
trajectory but at the same time there's
a small house movement that are building
amazing houses of a few hundred square
feet we're in the middle and I I think
you can build them more efficiently so I
think that built the built environment
could have a big shift in a big change
in a good way
also I've been working a lot with people
of the Department of Energy and there's
optimism and excitement there
what are they optimistic about not the
same thing you are suspect
northern and they're not building a
family and a house and settling route no
they're just I think there's some
optimism that we've made some progress
on things energy related and that things
are moving infrastructure is changing
we're building fewer coal plants we're
putting in ton of solar in the ground
the cost of solar is half what it was
when I talked this last time the cost of
wind is less than half of what it was
there still isn't any decent energy
storage for solar and wind still nitrous
an energy store
and the Tesla wall is not nearly on the
scale of that because you know the
energy storage problem yes we have the
daily one the energy storage problem
that's hard on the 50-year timeline is
winter is winter mm-hmm so we either
shuttle it back and forwards to the
southern hemisphere but there's only
there's not enough southern hemisphere
to balance the northern hemisphere but
so that's that's a big hard storage
problem that's probably why I biased
more of that that new pie chart if you
like towards nuclear and biofuels cuz
they they they have a better chance for
that some fuels must be better than
others because the corn-based ones sort
of got a bad reputation I don't think
there's a good biofuel yet but I think
that's erratically what would one be I
think you've got to look for north of a
tree with a tap in it the u-turn and jet
fuel comes out yeah the problem with the
problem of these pesky plants I love
plants I mean I really do I think plants
are great and super fascinating but the
problem is they don't just want to
produce you hydrocarbons they want to
live and they want to reproduce they
have in mind of their own and they spend
a huge amount of their energy doing that
right right so there's some really
boring plants that look like algae and
they don't do as much of all of the fun
things like reap they don't have as many
follies so they they are maybe three or
four percent efficient in biofuels is
microbial probably highly actually think
it's you're saying use of wood
sustainably farmed I think it's you know
agricultural by-product and I and you
know I think it's a mixture of all of
these things there is a lot of good work
and it's getting better the corn scandal
was a ridiculous boondoggle and we we
knew that people knew that that was
going to be the outcome so that was a
frustrating one but I think the 2000 to
2010 period will be known as maximum
energy hype minimum energy progress I
think now to 2025 looks like actually
the same solutions are emerging so maybe
those with the optimism is better work
on biofuels so we'll head toward
wrapping your River chute
that the your Australian trees that
eucalyptus or the best firewood I know
and they very kindly just drop the
branches every so often yeah they are
they are wonderful firewood they are
Lumberjacks nightmare they're horrible
yeah yeah they're hard and they got
knots they don't split well they're good
exercise I got this I've read this one I
was in a cabin recently and they had
these wonderful treatise on wood and
burning wood and they call it the fuel
that hates you twice when you chop it
down then when you burn it so I'm
looking to be hated twice oh yeah and
New England a tree about three times you
also carry it I was telling it sort of
general question and a lot of your
optimism a lot of your focus obviously
is on sort of counting on more and more
innovation more and more invention more
money to protect with various uses with
making politics make cities work better
and you focus pretty much on San
Francisco u.s. climate change is global
and actually most of the issue with
climate change is not the US which is
sort of tailing off in its greenhouse
gases that's not that's optimistic a lot
of its historical but you know the big
events are in places like China India
and elsewhere how's the innovation
inventiveness cities taking on these
kinds of infrastructure issues what's
your sense that the global prospects of
lots of people behaving in the ways that
you're talking about I think we need the
rest of the world to run experiments
that America want such as I small Asian
cities and European cities are gonna
more quickly deploy crazy alternatives
like hey let's all you know let's close
the city of London to four hundred watt
out for miles and open it only the 100
watt hour per mile picked over the
vehicles right London has already made
movements like that I think you're going
to see that in a ton of those places and
then those cities will be much
nice to live in than our big-box stores
and so eventually we'll move more city
design that way so I think that society
a question I think we want to run all of
these experiments as globally as you can
I gave the talk here we're all from San
Francisco I could use place names I
wanted to I wanted to familiarize you
with the realities of doing it ourselves
but then understanding that doing it
ourselves it's like we have to lean on
each other and our collective
infrastructure but the point of showing
you those slides at the end of lack you
know this is San Francisco if San
Francisco on the global scale is a very
high population density of City we can't
solve the problem here and I showed you
cities like Hong Kong and Macau and
Singapore they will never they can't
produce their energy but there there are
enough places and they're large enough
like Britain has a good chance by doing
a fair amount of nuclear to actually
take itself off greed if you let your
friend David Micajah factor suspect yeah
absolutely yeah David McKay wrote that
books spent a lot of time essentially as
Steven Chu is equivalent at the
Department of Energy and Climate Change
in Britain and they made a lot of I
think the British civil service does a
better job of reason based legislation
and and they did that their God you guys
have gotta fix your politics I'm gonna
have to get citizenship just so I can
help you vote correctly here Australia
being the model of how to do it right oh
my god
[Applause]
to say wow I mean we've had fought yeah
at least you've only had like a few bad
politicians in twenty years we've had
five and three years well if you use up
on all of them there's only good ones
left yeah I'm sorry
thank you this is fun we'll do it again
in a few years okay thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you